♪ Four and three and two and one
- I'm not talking to you.
I'm talking to my roommate.
- You're not my roommate.
- You two boyfriend
and girlfriend?
- God, no.
He's my roommate's boyfriend.
- [Man] So, you know his body?
- You were jerking off.
- I wasn't even
touching my wiener yet,
I was still just
doing butt stuff.
- Ew!
- I'm obviously straight,
but I would absolutely
suck him dry.
- Okay.
- Come on!
(moans)
The empire waist is
reading very Mormon.
I mean, we could let the
seam out an inch or two,
make it a little
less form-fitting,
but, I mean, you just
got those slut legs.
Ugh, next!
- What?
- Don't waste my time.
I could FaceTime with
you and watch you sleep.
- All right, bye.
- What are we doing?
What is this relationship?